c'est la fête des mères aujourd'hui et
on a décidé de célébrer ça avec la
visite de l'auteur fanny britt qui met
en lumière les différents modèles de
maman qui est avec moi en studio
aujourd'hui bonjour bonjour et donc qui
surtout refusent le modèle de la fameuse
mère parfaite on l'espère oui oui je
pense que c'est important de la refuser
cette mère parfaite là parce que elles
existent essentiellement pour je pense
créer une sorte de chape de plomb au
dessus de nous je pense pour quelque
part qu'on se sent pas libre de femmes
nos propres choix et comme un système
qui privilégie la cette idée qu'il faut
se conformer à un modèle et 3 de ce que
c'est une bonne mère je pense qu'au
final ça nous désavantage tout et vous
le voulez explorer ce sujet là dans le
tout dernier essai que vous publiez
d'ailleurs dans les prochains jours ce
mardi les retrancher échec et
ravissement de la famille en milieu de
course
vous êtes maman de deux garçons
voulaient subissez aussi c'est cette
pression là les pressions sociales
surtout depuis les médias sociaux de
défiler les fameuses photos de la
famille parfaite mais je pense que ça a
vraiment exacerbé ce phénomène là j'ai
l'impression que les fêtes comparaison
entre les familles ça se vit depuis plus
longtemps que les réseaux sociaux
évidemment mais je pense que toute cette
notion-là de mise en scène de la vie
privée qui est ensuite exposées sur la
place publique de manière aussi aussi
largement diffusé c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez nouveau donc
avant on pouvait se comparer nos voisins
puis regarder par la fenêtre mais on
avait un peu l'ensemble de leur vie on
les voyait de loin pire on pouvait aussi
voir les failles dans leur système
mais quand on est sur instagram on voit
seulement les images que les gens ont
choisi diffusé qui sont souvent
évidemment faux cils par rapport à
l'arrière et qu'est ce que ça fait
cesser ses pressions là c'est ça qui
fait en sorte que ces chemins de garçons
c'est ce qu'on a toujours ce doute ce
sentiment de culpabilité de dire ce que
je fais une bonne maman assez we fall
est assez oui oui faux les faux l'état
c'est sûr mais je pense que ça crée
aussi c'est une certaine notion qu'on
n'a pas droit d'avoir nos limites qu'on
n'a pas le droit de un moment donné
décidé que nous on veut s'arrêter par
exemple s'arrêter à deux enfants ou ou
avoir certaines limites par rapport à
notre carrière ou d'avoir besoin
d'espacé à nous puis en regardant ce que
les autres font sur les réseaux sociaux
par exemple on a l'impression que il
c'est pas correct d'avoir des limites
qu'il faut jamais dire non qu'il faut
toujours dire oui toujours plus en
accueillir plus en faire plus gagner
plus puis ça c'est très malsain je pense
parce que en fait qu'on apprend nos
enfants c'est sort quand on fait ça ce
qu'on apprend nos enfants c'est que ces
deux postes d'écouté de pas écouté que
par leur instinct qui leur dit non
là j'ai besoin de ralentir là j'ai
besoin d'aller chercher à l'intérieur de
moi faut que j'arrête de regarder vers
l'extérieur pour me définir notre que
sinon les conditions ne sont jamais de
limites
oui je pense que oui pis je dirais moshi
d'accord évidemment sur le fait de
vouloir se dépasser vouloir aller plus
loin et c'est sûr que c'est des bonnes
choses dans la vie de vouloir aller plus
loin puisse progresser mais comme il ya
comme une idée pour moi qui est raide
néolibérale
l'idée de la croissance à tout prix on
l'a beaucoup d'un système économique
mais je pense que ça c'est comme un peu
insérée aussi dans la sphère privée
cette idée là qu'il faut croître sans
cesse qu'il faut toujours en avoir plus
en faire plus puis je pense vraiment
pour des enfants c'est pressurisant
qu'on voit de plus en plus d'enfants qui
vivent de l'anxiété de performance mais
à un niveau que j'ai l'impression que ma
génération vivait pas en 5e 4e année des
enfants qui se sentent extrêmement
pressurisé à réussir et donc ce
sentiment là peut aussi en quelque sorte
provenir
selon ce que vous me dites de cette
pression qu'ont les maires aussi à la
maternité qui est un peu soumises à ce
capitalisme
oui si oui oui mais je pense vraiment
que on vit
dans une époque où tout est comme un peu
capitalisées en fait et même la vie de
famille donc j'ai l'impression que les
mâles subissent les par le subissent
dans une moindre mesure je pense que les
hommes ont toujours eu un peu plus la
liberté d'être eux-mêmes de choisir à
quoi ils vont consacrer leur temps
évidemment aussi que même si les
familles sont plus égalitaire qu'avant
c'est encore beaucoup les marques
prennent le gros de la charge la charge
temporel mais aussi la charge mentale et
même la charge émotionnelle qui est
cette idée d'être responsable du
bien-être de chacun est ce que tu te
sens bien est-ce que tu as eu une bonne
journée espèce d'inquiétude là qui nous
quitte jamais puis qui qui nous habite
un pays qui fait que l'on peut
rencontrer nos limites aussi un moment
donné n'ont qu'une remise en question
c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans cet essai
l'heure du rôle de la mère rôle qui est
gratifiant mais qui est au combien
difficile et ingrat aussi sur la foi qui
s'est essayé de mettre la pression un
peu de côté célébrer aussi en terminant
à fanny la diversité des modèles de
maman parce qu'ils en amérique où y'a
pas il n'y a pas un modèle de maman
parfaite l'euro n'ont absolument pas
fait ça je pense qu'on doit se
débarrasser de l'idée de n'ont pas
refait toute une famille parfaite puis
ensuite il faut je pense embrasser le
nos choix je les assume et puis pas
avoir peur de pas se conformer à quelque
chose peut correspondre à une image plus
juste y aller avec de l'amour avec la
solidarité je pense que c'est ça qui va
faire une belle famille ça fait du bien
d'entendre un discours lundi des mains
je souhaite une très très belle journée
oui oui non fanny britt mairie cellule
loin